greetings planet Houston why of General
Zod and may I wish you all a merry
zodmas
let us talk about this religious ritual
that you all gather around and watch it
every year the television what better
way to celebrate a man who wanted you to
help the poor by staying inside your
warm cozy house and watching your very
expensive cable first of all should be
know that on Krypton we do not have
television we mostly just stare at walls
rightfully colored walls mind you we
have giant holographic images of our
elders that stare at us in consternation
but thankfully no commercials the first
Christmas special I watched was called
the Christmas story it was about the
child who wish to procure a weapon
I admire of his exuberance but when he
finally gets the bloody thing
the pipsqueak shoots his eye out he
would make a poor soldier indeed in my
army he will be peeling spuds while my
cyberwarriors and nail then do my
bidding though I must admit I think I
got caught in a time loop for this
Christmas special seem to keep playing
over and over and over for exactly 24
hours I fear it might have been the son
of jor-el flying around the planet 24
times just to mess with me you were
stopping me from watching that damn
tickets group at the tea commercial
sanitarium however I did find a strange
attraction to this one special called
the Grinch I admire this Grinch and his
constant determination to try and take
over Christmas a goal I respect he is
resourceful but I fear I will not be
able to shake his hand as he seems to be
covered in a kryptonite dust the next
one I saw was called It's a Wonderful
Life well apparently it wasn't because
he tries to off himself in the first
part of the movie
I wouldn't mind except I wanted him to
jump that would have been the happy
ending the half man/half chairperson
would assimilate the town and I can
respect that instead we get some
nonsense about every time of thou rings
an angel gets his wings well on my
planet Krypton we have a saying too
every time at our lack D and blargh
blargh roars you get mustard on your
sandwich you've had to be a Kryptonian
to get that or at least have Krypton
ease then there came a Christmas carol
again named after this strange woman
I've never met though it did have an old
man and his servant
apparently mr. Crouch II do not
understand the whole master/slave
relationship
you do not complain about a lack of coal
you do you do not complain about your
child's debilitating disease your nails
you do not shed tears when your child
dies you thank him for his benevolence
that's one less mouth to feed that two
pens will go much farther now why would
you have so many children of your popper
to begin with I'm planet Krypton we are
only allowed to children
the rest are sent off to backwater
planets in Crystal cocoons we call that
no child left to get rid of the only
Christmas special I found myself
enjoying was the one called die hard
that had death destruction a perfect
Christmas film the only downside is they
killed the person with the goatee
dressed entirely in black I did not like
this
bald emic head hold down a marriage gets
off fine but the terrorist gets killed
now I've seen everything
final seven Christmas specials have no
place in the Sardinian People's Republic
of Houston unless of course they star me
in the Alan Rickman role and I live now
that's a happy ending this is General
Zod and you will all kneel before me